c'est pas mal et on pense à lui non
waouh j'adore très bien sortir avec un
mec comme avec quelqu'un comme cammas
[Musique]
c'est ma conseillère capillaire
maintenant à ma chérie ce toit qu'un
conseil sur mes coiffure alors elle en
fait elle a voulu que je fasse ça c'est
le dimanche soir qu'on fait pourquoi je
fais une flèche bleue parce que on sait
bleus dans ma vie ces bleus dans mon
coeur
[Musique]
nelson ont tout tout seul tôt
[Applaudissements]
cela
[Musique]
nagui populaire c'est ma mère prêté à
jamais la garder pour eux je vais la
garder car cela
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses chansons bonjour
est ce que est ce que tu vas faire tout
de suite le début de l'émission tu fais
le bon choix
mes choix
une
je
[Musique]